hello there reject nation I'm Greg Elbe
I'm John Humphrey no fun top or war tier
video here it's kind of a long one it is
from Patrick H Williams how Star Wars
trailers weaponized nostalgia obviously
hey this guy has like over two hundred
thousand subscribers and why almost
three hundred thousand he's a great
youtuber doing better than us right now
go subscribe to his channel as soon as
you can people big let's check this out
well hey Patrick listen break times over
we need to get back here but it's got
here time is faster on YouTube man
people ready forgot your name can't you
just get my parents to do it
now I tried they're in Hawaii with sage
for Thanksgiving mmm sage I think you
should be the first guy to make a video
about it you could talk about color
grading or your dumb felicity theory
look I told you a year ago
no more videos about Star Wars movies
these are the same thing about Mission
Impossible here I'm gonna send you away
no tricks this time I don't want 20
minutes of cats in space look I gotta go
I'm helping Thomas Frank launches music
career what
[Music]
he has an Empire Strikes Back wonder if
this is facing some former reality I'm
not going to make a video about Star
Wars movies I'll make one
[Music]
on November 13th 1998 the first trailer
for Star Wars Episode one The Phantom
Menace debuted in theaters in front of
the movie meet Joe Black yeah and it hit
the world with the force of multiple
speeding cars so many people bought
tickets just to see the trailer then it
boosted the box-office take for that
weird three hour movie where Brad Pitt
plays the Grim Reaper some theaters even
shove the trailer again after the movie
to convince people to sit through it
really this one trailer changed popular
culture assuring in an era in which the
mere release of marketing materials is
nearly as big a deal as the movie itself
really trailers frame by frame to try to
decipher hidden meanings and unearth
plot points it made trailers into events
and to this day no trailer is as big an
event as a Star Wars trailer maybe an
Avenger getting hit by the cars again
okay where to hook us no let's talk
about movie trailers through the history
of cinema trailers evolved from pretty
dull rudimentary previews that just
strung a handful of scenes together into
their own fascinating a learn way more
spoilery
[Music]
I'm not going to go as far as to call
them arts because they're not they're
pieces of marketing designed to sell you
something but while they're not art I
might argue with that and they chose an
artistic medium arranging elements so as
to express an idea but while arts does
this to express the artists personal
vision trailers communicate the idea
that you need to see you this bog down
movie and a few trailers Davis as well
is still holy as the trailers for Lucas
Films current Star Wars trilogy they're
not just cramming a bunch of cool shots
and plenty jokes into two minutes
they're designed to give the viewer a
powerful emotional experience while also
over the course of five years
communicate an evolving idea about the
series these don't have the depth of
actual movies because again there are
just pieces of marketing designed to
sell stuff but there's some really
fascinating crafts on display and as
examples of film editing that I think
they're worth analyzing so now I step it
into our turf clear what we'll be
talking about it's the two teasers and
the final trailer for the force awakens
the teaser and final trailer for the
last Jedi and the teaser and final
trailer for the rise of Skywalker 7
trailers that's it let's go
[Music]
badda ministers much a vehement
important trailer in film history i
would argue that the first teaser for
the force awakens is a pretty close
second - being an awakening have you
felt it
it might have been nine years since the
last Star Wars movie but it would be
continuing the story that left off in
1983 and bringing back the original
characters right somehow no one really
knew what what this movie would be the
force awakens teaser had to reintroduce
Star Wars set the tone and establish the
meta-narrative of the marketing that
would continue over the next five years
through the whole trilogy we'll get back
to that part in a bit look we've all
serviced trailer and we probably all
know it by heart I still remember
exactly where I was sitting when it hit
the Internet on November 28th 2015
look at the trailer itself breakdown
what it's doing we had all waited nine
years for a look at new Star Wars and
then the trailer begins and it makes us
wait even more it slowly fades in I
static shot of a desert and nothing
happens for a full 10 seconds and then
for the following minute after every
shot the trailer cuts back to black
making us wait and hold our breath for
the next one it's reinforcing that same
idea that made people pay money to watch
that phantom and his trailer back in 98
the idea that Star Wars footage is
valuable and precious and we should
savor every second up yes yes
every business it's a mix of old and new
the desert setting and stormtrooper
armor are familiar to us but what's not
familiar is seeing a stormtrooper
without his helmet portrayed as a real
character and also a black stormtrooper
and each successive shot continues this
mix of old and new we've got a practical
protocol droid in a desert scrapyard
that's familiar but it's a new kind of
ball droid we've never seen before
it's got stormtroopers but this time
with
subjective filmmaking shot from their
perspective with handheld camera work
we've got a desert inertia the land
speeder but with a new character and a
speeder design we've never seen
we've got rebel pilots flying X wings
but they're flying inside a planet's
atmosphere over water and of course
there's a villain in a black cloak but
he has this crazy new kind of lights a
shot not at all there's music playing
that is clearly by John Williams but
it's not using any familiar Star Wars
themes familiar but different of all of
this is overwhelming we're excited and
anxious and trying to take it all in
reconcile this mix of familiar and new
in every shot our brains are screaming
what is going on where there's no
context we don't fully understand what
we're looking at and then it cuts to
black again and we wait and then it hits
[Music]
yeah Tyrone was freaking out I mean
super brainz the end of this video
straight to the pleasure centers of our
brains it's like taking a drug it's new
and cool and scary and then the trailers
that Stewart rush of euphoria wait what
am I talking about I don't know anything
about drugs I'm an anxious nerd who's
afraid of everything the trailer gives
us a lot of new stuff to take in and
process and in the end rewards us with
the nostalgia we crave the warm feeling
of the Star Wars we know and love yeah
sugar that makes the medicine go down
even if that medicine is also pretty
cool and that idea the use of classic
elements from the original trilogy as
payoffs and rewards the interplay
between old and new is what would drive
all the trailers for these movies yeah
the exact same thing happens in the
second teaser for the force awakens this
is the one that's basically a big
build-up to this Chewie Oh looks like
Lucasfilm is making a deal with the
audience you sit through the first two
minutes you pay attention to the new
stuff and then as a reward you get to
see your friends Han and Chewie again
this is the moment where everyone
screams and cries and punches their
friends because they're so excited hey
there's javi Manish is the running
meta-narrative that continues now I'm
what the trailers are really
communicating to us is the transition
from the old generation to a new one it
uses familiar elements to get us
invested in the unfamiliar ones it uses
our nostalgia to sell us on something
new
it's a lot of movies now this teaser
begins with John Williams iconic force
theme aka in the binary sunset played on
a solo French horn when we hear that we
think of this
[Music]
that original feeling of yearning for
something more for some kind of
adventure and here is played over images
of the destroyed iconography of the
original trilogy a crashed Star
Destroyer Darth Vader's ruined helmet
what appears to be Luke's old lightsaber
and there's a voiceover from Luke
Skywalker which isn't from the new movie
at all it's just taken from Return of
the Jedi before is the stone in my
family
young mark hamill boys
I have my sister but here stripped of
its original context in that film when
he says you have that power too it feels
like he's addressing the new characters
from this movie yes the trailer
immediately cuts to a montage of them
the only characters we see in close-up
or the leaves of the new movie rey finn
kylo Ren and Poe and the image we see
right before Luke's line is a lightsaber
being handed from one person to another
it's literally a torch being passed you
have that power too in time this
dialogue originally from 32 years
earlier is used to bridge two
generations it's the magic of trailer
editing using old material in a new
context to communicate an idea to make
the new characters seem important to
audiences because Luke Skywalker's
telling them they are we care yeah I
feel like that's a creative arts and put
that together in the final trailer for
the force awakens this is where we need
to start talking about the music
starting with this one all the trailers
for the series would use primarily newly
recorded music with other composers such
as Frederic Lloyd John Samuel Hansen
Chris Westlake and Blake Robinson
rearranging John Williams I feel like it
this is this marketing approaches super
appropriate though for horse awaiting a
character's considering what the horse
was before did it rewards us with
nostalgia as the trailer cuts to the
Millennium Falcon a new arrangement of
Han Solo and the princess kicks in the
original recording from Empire Strikes
Back sounds like this
[Music]
ah the smell of feet no it's a sweeping
epic anthem full of hans zimmer ask
precaution
[Music]
and as soon as it begins even in its new
form we have that hit of nostalgia we're
reminded of Han and Leia and then
moments later han himself appears this
midway point in the trailer establishes
something each film's final trailer
would do a brief scene in the middle
that connects the old generation and the
new so here Han is talking to Rey and
Finn the full trailers for the last Jedi
and the rise of Skywalker would take
this further by slowing the trailer down
to let the audience sit in this
emotional moment the last Jedi's trailer
cuts out all music for a long moment
between kylo Ren and Leia the shooter
the trailer cuts back and forth between
close-ups of their faces linking old and
new mother and son the new trailer for
the rise of Skywalker applauses in the
middle for a scene with the heroes of
the new trilogy talking to c-3po who
refers to them as creepy Oh was once the
friend of Luke han and Leia and now has
been passed down to the heroes of the
new trilogy see through that it's pretty
much the most emotional moment I can
recall c-3po having in the entire series
and the music underscoring it is Yoda's
theme we're doing there a triple taking
one last look so most people watching
aren't going to notice that on first
viewing
I mean def I didn't but it gives us some
conscious reminder of other beloved
supporting characters from the original
films
[Music]
old and new are connected via dialogue
and via music for what is again a piece
of marketing it's pretty powerful stuff
hi it's me again sorry for the
interruption I just wanted to bring
something up because we're talking about
Star Wars they're talking about I am so
not I read the tremendous video called
solving the mystery of JJ Abrams ever
mind in which I attempt to figure out
Farrah Abraham's is as a storyteller
and what he'll do with episode 9 by
watching all 84 episodes of the TV
series felicity the first show he ever
created and the only long-running
project he ever stayed on until the end
so I want to go on the record again with
my theory about how the rise of
Skywalker will end and yes I'm basing
this 100% on Felicity
first off there will be time travel
secondly ray and kylo Ren but if they're
together like romantically and finally
she'll end up back home on jakku where
she started now do I want this to happen
not really what are the odds that it
will very poor like a thousand to one
but I'm sticking with this theorem as
well saying doesn't keep me mad to the
video and to get back to the music like
the other trailers in the series there
are some really interesting things
happening the teaser for the last Jedi
is mostly focused on Reyes training as
she learns more about the force and the
music overlaps Ray's theme
[Music]
and the force theme
[Music]
binary some favorite Star Wars cute
[Music]
so while we see these images of her
learning more about the force the music
is reinforcing it by doing the exact
same like get it becoming one it builds
to a climax where the music goes into
epic action mode but now it ships
between an epic version of the force
theme
[Music]
in an epic version of race tea
in John Williams score for the force
awakens the final track is called the
Jedi steps and it's literally the
soundtrack to two generations meeting as
rey arrives on octo to deliver the
lightsaber to Luke
and continuing the trailers theme of
transitioning from one generation to the
next the final trailer for the last Jedi
uses the Jedi steps throughout like this
the rise of Skywalker teaser takes the
ongoing narrative of the new generation
replacing the old and makes it even more
explicit the opening scene speaking to
her and let's listen to what he says the
thousand generations live in Yuna ah
there's the word generation again and
then what does the text in the trailer
say hey there it is I wonder if that's
what they've been getting at for the
past five years the trailer is mostly
set to a sweeping epic version of
Princess Leia's theme
- thank God Carrie Fisher there's that
connection to the original films and
then get the shot of Leia herself
especially with the knowledge that
Carrie Fisher passed away two years ago
it hits even harder and importantly in
the shine is Steven Rae a big ol hug
we've got the connection between old and
new andreas crying and maybe I am too I
don't know and just like the original
force awakens trailers we have the final
payoff of older classic elements the
image of the Death Star and the sound of
Palpatine's laughs but instead of joyous
this payoff is ominous the narrative
here seems to be that in distraction
from one generation to the next the
final step for the new generation is to
overcome the same challenge that the
previous one faced so maybe that's the
plot of the movie I don't know
we'll find out soon but now what there's
the latest trailer the final trailer the
last trailer of this entire trilogy it
begins as almost all of them have with
Rey some of the early imagery with her
climbing through the wreckage and old
Imperial ships directly calls back to
the first trailer to the force away
salsa force already playing on our
nostalgia for four years ago but
musically this is doing a lot like more
than I can really analyze myself because
I don't really know anything about music
theory so I brought him someone who does
so Brian Metolius is a friend of mine
who's a really television composer I've
worked with him on a bunch of projects
and he also happens to be an expert on
John Williams Star Wars music so God
want a call right here Brian thank you
for joining us can you break down what
is going on musically in this Star Wars
trailer all right so that beginning
section is in the key of D that section
is meant to be like Star Wars flavored
like stuck like a like a la croix is to
a lime as this music is to Star Wars
music it uses the harmonic language of
Star Wars it will feel like Star Wars
without using any recognizable theme
so in the first section of this trailer
there's this horn part that kind of
slowly rises up toward the foreground of
the music what's going on with that oh
yeah yeah so that that that horn part is
actually from Laius ding but it's not
the melody it's actually what's called
the counter melody and it's something
that runs along with but against the
melody so here's Leia's theme and now
listen for the horn part
beautiful I meant
that's actually pre-existing material
from a new hope that's meant to go along
with lay esteem but Laius theme is
nowhere to be heard
so it's essentially Laius theme without
Leia
it's Leia's theme music without the
melody the trailer seems to be aware
that everyone is aware that Carrie
Fisher is no longer with us I could be
reading into that way too much and
probably am but the trailer does say I'm
going to have one last look at my
friends and like a second later Ray is
embracing Carrie Fisher so all bets are
off
after that section with Leia steam the
music builds and builds and builds in it
cuts out when we get a close-up of and
they really want us to pay attention to
what is being said here and the way they
do that is basically by bringing the
ball you've down in the music and by
reor castrating it so that it's just the
high woodwinds we're doing there in
street view the high wood ones are
playing Yoda's theme actually even
though Yoda is nowhere to be seen
[Music]
the chords Yetta will make a nice theme
that everyone knows what you actually
are doing is going from D major to E
major so D major E major I played along
on the piano to this trailer dozens of
times and I think it was maybe about the
fifth or sixth time that I realized why
they're using Yoda's theme there when
there's really no official reason to and
it really comes down to it telegraphing
the key change that's coming immediately
afterwards Yoda's theme is interesting
harmonically because it basically has
the tonic chord which is d major and
then it goes immediately up to E major
what that does it sets you up for the
big title card this Christmas which is
where the key changes to E major so
beginning section is indeed
you got the Yoda section in the middle
are you doing there in three bill taking
one last looks which it's very short but
it does go de de so it's like pull it's
like pulling in either direction and
then immediately afterwards BAM
you got your E major Center and that a
major section is the music that we all
know and love the opening title crawl
but an E major and the opening title
crawl as it's used right here in the
trailer is like a chorus from a pop song
it repeats it several times
it even reharmonization
just to make sure that you're not
getting tired of it and it got there by
doing a step up key change some examples
of this are I want it that way by the
battery boys and probably the most
famous key change I can think of is
Whitney Houston's I'll always love you
[Music]
it's a very powerful powerful
compositional technique the trailer just
essentially the same thing
it goes from D major to E major and hits
that familiar music that you know and
love several times as if it were a
course in a new key and it brings the
house down
so essentially the person who put
together this trailer music treated all
the themes as if it were a pop song for
the greatest dramatic effect that was
great
Brian thank you so much for joining us
and helping explain all this so smart
couldn't have done myself that's so
smart the black backdrop I think so
maybe you're watching this going home
Patrick I'm okay these are just trailers
intended for children there's not that
much to analyze and to that I say yes
there totally is do you really think
Disney isn't putting everything into the
marketing for some of the most
anticipated movies of all time that
they're not hiring the best editors who
are using every editing trick in the
book to subconsciously influence us I'm
pretty sure everything that I've
mentioned here was totally intentional
plus probably a bunch more tricks that I
missed it works like this the more
goosebumps we get from these trailers
the more money they're going to make ah
but what a rogue one and solo the other
Star Wars movies released story that is
the era a a thousand of ecore Skywalker
saga they're both directly tied to it so
there's plenty of nostalgia to weaponize
rogue one takes a popular trailer trend
and applies it to Star Wars you know all
those trailers set to sad slow covers of
pop songs
well these trailers use sad slow piano
versions of the horse theme and the
Imperial March it works
it gives us that hit of nostalgia but
with a new feeling yeah
the trailers are filled with the
original trilogy rebel pilots who have
been become part of the problem or
destroyers the death star from a
perspective and in a style we haven't
seen before it's darker and grittier and
you know what that is appealing to a lot
of people it's doing a similar thing to
the sequel trilogy shown this stuff we
already know but in a way that feels new
and rogue one made a billion dollars so
you know what I guess it worked and then
there's the weird cases and solo oh the
bastard stepchild of Star Wars it's a
prequel about one of the most popular
characters in the entire series there is
so much nostalgia there for the trailers
to tap into but instead they just ignore
most of it the only original John
Williams theme they use is this quick
burst of the force theme at the end that
honestly sounds like it came from a
theme park ride
the general principle of every Star Wars
trailer has always been give the
audience goosebumps and the solo
trailers don't even seem to try is this
the reason the movie was way less
successful than all the others I doubt
it's that simple but I think that's part
of a kit ploy I mean what kind of Star
Wars trailer doesn't make you feel
something every Star Wars trailer has
always made the movie seem important and
the solo trailers just seemed kind of
throwaway in disposable now I want to
reiterate these trailers are pieces of
marketing Martin Scorsese would not call
them cinema and you know what neither
would i but they use cinematic language
and tools in a way that I think is worth
studying there's an emotional journey
across these 15 minutes worth of
trailers the introduction of a new
generation and the departure of an older
one the final rise of Skywalker trailer
ends with a close-up of ray our new
protagonist hearing the voices of Luke
and Leia it's telling us that while
they'll always have those original
elements from the original movies that
we know and love the story has changed
hands to a new generation of characters
the cycle is complete so when you get
chills or tear off watching one of these
things it's because these editors are
very good at their job and they know
exactly how to weaponize your nostalgia
ha got the title in there one more time
all right let's roll it again yeah okay
it's done you got your Star Wars video
can I please go back to the beach now
yeah in a minute
first thing though did you know that
somebody made a whole Skillshare of
course that had a new sponsor sideways
like you wait what I didn't realize the
way I didn't sponsor segways was
actually that unique I mean all I do is
look for some excuse to bring up a
specific class like the one day we did
about color grading I mentioned that
it's on Skillshare and this kill shirt
is an online learning community with
thousands of classes and yeah I mean
that course is really good now bring it
home its sponsor time
for well you know I care probably too
much about color grading and if you
wanna know more about it like how it
works what it means and how to do it
yourself
you should check out this class color
grading for filmmaking the vision art
and science by dan dan blue and yeah
it's on Skillshare who I'm really happy
keeps supporting this channel because it
is a great site that I actually use a
lot there are thousands of classes
they're not just about filmmaking but
about everything from music to cooking
to interior design if you sign up now at
the link in the description you can get
two months of unlimited classes totally
free so many skills can be shared and
learned in two months so go click that
link sign up help out the channel and
learn some stuff hello welcome back and
hey I'm back to like really I took it
easy for the past month but now I'm
feeling refreshed excited to be making
new videos again I want to give a huge
thanks to my friend at Bryan metolius
for helping out with this video
Bryan is a brilliant composer who I've
worked with on videos on this channel
and on a theme songs for my patrons man
he's also the composer for the hit
off-broadway play puffs there's a link
in the description to his site so
seriously go hire him he's great you
know so much about Sean Williams also
very important announcement our official
merch store is now open
yes there is a shirt that says this is a
movie about space wizards intended for
children so if that's the kind of thing
that you want link is down there go buy
some stuff go check out the patreon to
support the channel and get access to
exclusive stuff listen to can't get
enough Keanu and the infinity podcast
every week go visit our subreddit and
follow me on those social medias I'll
see you in a couple weeks
good bye
[Music]
look at all those patrons soon they
could be ours
they just see this reaction they're like
ah
bye-bye proxy we have to are primarily
just listening reaction yes occasionally
commenting laughing you know yeah hey
we've been sponsored by Skillshare -
look at that yes although not in this
video
dianna the names don't stop no they
never go so many names come on here this
can't get enough he on a podcast
I know it's playing into my nostalgia
for kyon designs do so it's weird
nostalgia is a positive thing it really
is and for some reason when I write here
brought up on the internet or in film
circles it seems like there's this
undertone of cynicism to the word now of
everything is about nostalgia now it's
like the way they make bean woke to be a
negative thing now you know really am i
why is this why is this exactly negative
because so when I heard the title House
Star Wars trailers weaponize nostalgia I
immediately assumed we were walking into
a video that was gonna be all about how
Star Wars manipulates you and that this
is a negative thing just because of the
way that title sounded come to find out
it's really just an analysis it's just a
pretty town I kept waiting for the
here's why stop now that's where I
thought it was going and never went
there there's a video we covered from
vice news called how movie trailers
manipulate you
that video was eight minutes long or
something but then our discussion based
off of it to essentially became our own
video about it oh yeah a lot of editing
went into that one I really recommend
you guys check that out because yeah I
do you think there's something to be
studied about trailers specifically and
I think naturally sequel trailers are
going to do that
any any movie that is a sequel is gonna
play into your nostalgia or just
sticking to the topic here force awakens
I think is incredibly appropriate to do
that
because you're taking in the context of
you have the original trilogy decades go
by or like a decade and a half of hoof
and then you get the prequels and
there's a major letdown
and then you get this announcement of a
new trilogy with new players involved
and the old returning cast so the whole
point I think well force awakens was
trying to solidify that it's even in the
film itself it's got a lot of criticism
for being just a soft reboot of a new
hope in a lot of ways like to me that
was never a nostalgia thing that was
upsetting I always understood it now it
seems like they really heavily rely on
it to the point where I can go back and
forth since being super excited cuz
honestly whenever they played Rises
Skywalker footage here I was like yeah
that felt that and then there's the
other side where occasionally it just
depends on the mood I'm in I'll be
watching the trailer and the theaters
before a movie starts and I go this is
working on because of its nostalgia and
I'm not as excited about the new stuff
and the new characters and I feel like
by now when you're wrapping up this new
trilogy it should be playing more into
that side of things as opposed to just
the nostalgia from the original trilogy
you know and I think that's the exact
thing that causes people to get cynical
the exact algin in the first place
because as we've just seen I feel like
Terminator dark fate has been just like
a constant reference point like even in
a lot of videos we've been watching
lately you can even point at that movie
and see that there are using that
nostalgia and playing with your feelings
to get you in but they're not
necessarily with all these movies that
use that technique delivering something
respectful to the thing they're using
your nostalgia for over you know sure
and I think that's gonna be the big
maker or breaker for rise of Skywalker's
sort of by the end of this is it gonna
feel like we love Finn rape oh the new
players or are we gonna be like oh wow
I'm glad that we got the
original cast - there you know conclu
this is the end of the Skywalker saga
but you know does that mean that episode
10 or the new episode 1 is going to be a
new race agha
yeah like and and if that's the case you
know are people truly going to be
invested if that nostalgia then goes
away III mean I don't know without
trying to theorize too much about Rises
Skywalker in and of itself I'm kind of
surprised by how much they've seemed
like they've tripled down on the
nostalgia fest yes I was going to dive a
little bit more into a rise of Skywalker
yeah and I think that that plays in tune
with how Force awakens was a nostalgia
fest marketing campaign yeah the movie
itself in a lot of ways this is a
nostalgia fest
yeah and then they did the last Jedi
which seemed to break all the rules yeah
exactly
and then that just pissed off a lot of
people yeah we're not included in that
camp but we are well aware okay it may
have been a bit of an overcorrection for
some people right now there's been a lot
of talk with this movie of are they
gonna just do their own thing JJ Abrams
has talked about how he actually had
some influence from speaking with Rian
Johnson before going into production on
this film were just doing his own thing
the trailers don't seem to support I
think the marketing especially I don't
know about the movie itself yeah I mean
the Emperor's in there I don't know
about the movie in and of itself but the
trailers are definitely trying to be
like no don't worry this is gonna be the
Star Wars you love yeah yeah totally and
it works on me when I'm watching it
that's why I mean by a joke that I'm
part of the problem it works because it
works on me all these
live-action/animated remakes of Disney
films work on me because when I see the
trailers and then I watch the movies and
I'm let down I've noticed that it's like
a lot of time kind of letdown Lion King
I was super excited about and then I was
like that's the tricky thing about
trailers is you can make a great trailer
out of it like anything you have to ish
hours worth of footage for you can cut
into an amazing two minutes if you want
to right you know and so that's the
tricky thing about it well I see
I can't I guess I can meet him halfway
here on the idea that trailers aren't
art they're just marketing I wouldn't
say they're not creative though no he
doesn't either yeah he doesn't he
doesn't either but to me you know that
for an artist's objective like most
things but hardest subjective and I
think anything creative in and of itself
can be an art and I feel like there is
an art to putting together a great
trailer it's commercial art sure I would
meet like halfway there and say cuz you
wouldn't have the trailer without the
thing it's trying to sell you wouldn't
need it yeah but for like an editor to
have to work on composing something have
you ever seen a bad trailer for a movie
that's great we've done plenty of those
used to have a segment that I keep
thinking of bringing back up called
trailers revisited which is the segment
we were doing for a while watching the
original trailer for a movie that we've
already seen breaking down how well does
it commune and I feel like that segment
is will really help me appreciate the
art of trailers because that showed me
that it's a it's a you have to
communicate a lot about what the actual
movie is so the whole point of that
segment was to go does this trailer
communicate the characters the tone the
feel what is it not communicating about
the movie that we actually got from
watching the film you see like what's
solo I think they were in it's kind of
like this is not really a smooth
transition here because solo I think
they're know this weird position because
that whole thing is all nostalgia more
than rogue one most of its heavily leans
in the movie itself and I feel like they
were in this conundrum where I think
they are aware of cynicism that's
applied to it so they tried pitching us
like no this is essential this is new
when that really backfired on them I
think they'll really stay close to last
Jedi yadda yadda yadda but just terms of
talking about why I think they chose to
do the trailers the way they did was
because the movie itself is so in this
knowledge that that they were trying to
tell us no there's a reason you gotta
watch this this is new and different
yeah and he even brings up that of all
the Star Wars the new Star Wars trailers
it is the one that does that the
least and funny enough for me he said
like you know it kind of just plays like
another action movie trailer and when I
saw that movie I oddly feel like the
trailer matches the movie really well
cuz to me I was like yeah this is a fine
action adventure movie and it's a fine
trailer for a fine action adventure
movie it doesn't get me particularly
excited in one direction or the other
which is just funny and I think you're
right is like yeah the whole movie is
taking place inside of a nostalgia
bubble you know yes we're gonna go flesh
out Han for you in case you want to see
all the things that were briefly talked
about yeah so run and all those things
you know and I think that just shows
what happens when you're only having
that to work with perhaps yeah or you're
not really trying to make it new beyond
that cuz you know solo didn't seem like
it was trying to introduce anything that
was mind-blowing leave I knew I liked
the breakdown of the songs that they
were talking about - it's like these
slight changes and notes and keys
it just keeps doing the familiar but
different thing it's very apparent what
they're doing but also movies do that
like The Matrix trilogy everyone was the
same opening song on the Warner Brothers
logo but they slightly change it's like
you have two episodes of television do
that with their theme songs a lot of the
time it's like as they keep going they
do the same thing but they slightly
change it is the natural thing of when
an art piece grows there has all these
different factories of surrounding it
and yeah I mean I think that was just a
fascinating thing to realize because you
noticed the music in a trailer but you
don't necessarily notice all that it's
doing and what I appreciated so much
about the breakdown is he really
bothered to analyze what it's doing and
how much you see the funny thing is I
feel like it's easy to get a braced a
little bit by that declaration at the
beginning that these are art they're
marketing but at the same time I do have
to really appreciate the level of
sophistication it would take to link all
these things together as the person
assembling this trailer going okay for
c-3po you know a familiar character with
a sort of wise aura we're gonna take
Yoda's theme and the subconscious that
that plays on for you because yeah it's
like I wouldn't necessarily have thought
of yours
I don't know the names of hardly any of
the Star Wars Q's but at the same time
he pointed out these things I was like
yeah that's how I was feeling at the
time that was playing and so I don't
know who knows music theory who's
cutting a trailer but it does seem like
they're able to harness and use it and
that's just fascinating sure I get why
you would argue about the artistic merit
of a movie trailer but I do think it
does exist in its own because of what he
pointed out with like the the first
Phantom Menace trailer you're making
trailers themselves events I think that
that is its own little bubble of
creation yeah you're not expressing
something that isn't based on a larger
piece of source material what about one
like a person who does like tribute
videos on YouTube takes a movie and then
re-edits it I feel like that kind of
discredits a lot I mean he was given a
lot of credit and was given a lot of
praise to the power of editing so I'm
not like complete disagreeing with him
like I know an editor and her chronic
whose dream was ultimately lot to get
into film but what he really wants to do
is he wants to edit movie trailers he
likes the idea of taking the whole movie
and try and doing your best to
communicate the story and sell the
sizzle the whole the whole thing and to
me it's kind of like saying the editor
of it is not doing something artistic
one yeah I think it is there's also the
fact that on the marketing yeah its own
art cuz we all saw it happen with
suicide yeah when they let the trailer
house cut the mean of course there's a
marketing aspect where they're like we
have to make sure we're doing this so
they got to work with that you know yeah
I mean I honestly feel like it doesn't
matter like that the qualification of
art I think is an interesting thing to
argue over there's gonna be a thing we
get hung up I know I'm not welcome and I
think that whether or not you think of
movie trailers art I don't think you can
argue that they're not creative and that
they call upon a lot of craft and it is
like if you're the person cutting them
it is art like it also it just depends
on who's looking at it from what angle
yeah I can never ignore the asterisk
that a movie trailer is only in
existence truthfully to sell you a movie
whether or not that movie is good so I
get what is to be argued about there
because there is a manipulation
happening
if the movie is good it's not a
manipulation if it's not it it is yeah
you know yeah cuz it's not as easy as
just sound cues and good cutting you
know yeah yeah it takes instinct and it
takes for Star Wars especially I'm sure
a good knowledge of that not that
anybody who's cutting trailers probably
doesn't have a you know a good knowledge
of the source the thing that he really
brought to light which is so brief here
mm-hmm
but it hit me on why they actually do
this when he was talking about it I
never understood this trend of taking
songs that have these dark remixes to
them and then putting them on all these
trailers I didn't get why that was
trending I was like oh cuz it worked for
a couple of movies but it's true what
he's saying that to me is manipulative
because sometimes it really works we
were like that song really fits at reson
other times it has nothing to do with
the movie it's not gonna be in the movie
it's not a representation of the movie
but it is factoring into your nostalgia
yeah it's kind of like emotional it's
like it's factoring in to your nostalgia
like oh I love this song this is a
different verb that has nothing
different than the Star Wars yeah but
that Association makes you go oh I like
this trailer I want to see this movie oh
yeah
and that's why I think a lot of trailers
are either using those dark remixes or
just using popular songs now in general
which is great for trailer if that's
something you can point to across the
art form as a whole is like here's a
technique that works if you're using it
the right way and it complements it but
it's totally Hollow if you're just using
it willy-nilly cuz it's popular but it
hit me that's why they do that yeah and
I'd never understood it until this video
yeah I hadn't even clicked onto that
idea that they just want you to go oh
yeah I love California dreamin so I like
this interesting version of paying
attention yeah guys do you agree with
what Patrick H Williams is talking about
do you think trailers are art comment
below make make sure to subscribe to
Patrick H Williams I know that John's
been a follower of him for a
while we were already subscribed because
of you thank you I do a lot really I did
subscribe make sure to subscribe to him
as soon as you can subscribe to the real
rejects click our notification irelia
notify whatever got a youtube video
check us on patron as well garage thank
you so much dude I really appreciate you
sending this over originally it sent
over a music video but most of its like
it's even with videos that aren't music
videos will get blocked it's because of
music in it yeah so thank you for
readjusting and good I feel like this
one sparked a whole new kind of thought
process that I thought oh so enriching
you dude I hope you have a really happy
Thanksgiving man I am grateful for you
and ladies if you want to get some
stuffing from a hot Indian guy oh yeah
or I don't think he's gay or just a guy
from New Jersey if you're gay persuade
Niraj oh yeah good stuffing same joke
hey get that get that cranberry sauce we
don't want to talk about his condition
yeah he got a vasectomy occasionally
he's gonna bleep I'm sorry
your Lord Krishna
[Music]